he left his ak-47 with us
safe in the uk but still not settled
this former interpreter is grateful to
be out of afghanistan yet after two
months he's still waiting for somewhere
in this country to call home
for now stuck with his wife and child in
a house for the homeless along with
other families
he asked to remain anonymous not wanting
to upset the home office or the taliban
it is uncomfortable yeah it's a small
place but we have to manage until they
find the place they're not guaranteeing
us how long it will take but they are
giving us hopes that they're they're
working on this issue to find the houses
and then we will move there but but not
exact time that how long it will take
he's not alone the uk airlifted
thousands of people from kabul as the
taliban took over
but the home office has yet to find the
majority a permanent place to live
leaving many in limbo
some 800 refugees are split between
three hotels in london's richest borough
the prestige of kensington and chelsea a
stark contrast to the poverty of
afghanistan but not a long-term solution
to be in a hotel of course it's
lovely it's it's asylum for a week or
whatever but you want to move on you
want to be able to put down routes and
settle and get on with your life you
can't do that in a hotel
for veterans like simon who've been
helping afghan interpreter friends
there's disappointment more isn't being
done faster
we need to get them into place where
they can start to start to settle they
can start to not just survive but thrive
a failure to act could turn relief among
afghans into resentment or even make
some susceptible to radicalization by
extremists a dislocated set of
expectations
not been treated properly
it could be some stupid casual racism
whatever and then they go do you know
what i don't know why i wasted my life
working for them i've got no there's
another message here telling me how i
should live my life and that's when they
become open i think to to to
radicalization messages
for this former interpreter he's still
hopeful the home office will live up to
its name
and find his family somewhere suitable
to live
debra haynes sky news